avec nous maintenant pour faire le point
jimmy jean qui est économiste en chef
chez desjardins bonsoir soit on
attendait une première hausse du taux
directeur dans la deuxième moitié de
2022 lassé avril 2022 qu'est ce que ça
vous indique parce qu'on se dit au
niveau de la banque du canada
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on donne une plage
en fait c'est qu'on dit que ça pourrait
être dans un horizon qui a erré 2 avril
2022 à septembre 2022 donc son prend le
point milieu ça sera environ juillet et
nous on avait prévu le coup j'ai déjà
mais on avait ajusté nos prévisions à
juillet 2022 pour la première hausse de
taux donc c'est pas une grande surprise
que la banque du canada nous attendent
nous annonce aujourd'hui l'inflation
était plus forte qu'elle le prévoyait
les pressions sont un petit peu plus
persistante et donc attendre un an c'est
beaucoup trop long way et à combien de
reprises pensez-vous qu'en 2022 le taux
sera relevé et dans quelle fourchette
avez vous une idée je sais qu'on n'a pas
de boule de cristal mais selon vous nous
notre hypothèse c'est qu'on va commencer
en juillet on va poursuivre avec une eau
sera probablement en octobre donc ça
devrait faire de 11 en 2022 donc 50
points de base d'augmentation des taux
on pense que la banque du canada va
quand même y aller de façon graduelle
parce que en une économie qui est très
sensible aux taux d'intérêt on l'a vécu
quand la banque du canada avait monté
ses taux en 2017 et 2018 il ya eu un
ralentissement qui s'est fait sentir sur
le tard en 2019 évidemment il y avait
d'autres facteurs derrière cela mais il
ya un ralentissement dans toutes les
composantes de la consommation qui
dépendent énormément des taux d'intérêt
évidemment il ya le secteur immobilier
m'a tout ce qu'ils dépensent en
rénovation tout ce qui est consommation
de biens durables des achats à crédit et
qui sont rattachés à l'immobilier ça va
ralentir et le cas actuel ne sera pas
différent étant donné ce qu'on a vécu
durant cette pandémie qui est une hausse
fulgurante de l'activité sur le marché
immobilier
c'est certain qu'il va avoir un
ralentissement de ce côté là donc le
monde se connaît quand même y aller de
prudence pour faire en sorte que ce se
refermant le devienne pas trop
déstabilisés mais c'est peut-être la
bienvenue en même temps la banque du
canada annonce également la fin de son
programme d'assouplissement quantitatif
où on est venu ajouter le 350 milliards
dollars dans le bilan financier en
rachetant des obligations du
gouvernement fédéral c'est un programme
qui est venu soutenir le système
financier en maintenant les taux
obligataires un faible niveau en
injectant des liquidités dans le système
quel sera l'impact maintenant de cette
décision c'est quelque chose qui était
prévu encore une fois on anticipait que
la banque du canada allaient nous
annoncer un passage en mode de
réinvestissement au niveau de son bilan
ce qu'on nous dit c'est que
l'assouplissement quantitatif
c'est une mesure d'urgence qui n'est
clairement plus nécessaire dans un
contexte où on a de l'inflation donc la
banque du canada et paris vient pas de
décider ça d'un coup de tête elle avait
déjà commencé le processus depuis le
mois d'avril dernier donc on y va de
manière graduelle à ce niveau là et on a
vu sur la réaction du marché aujourd'hui
c'est pas vraiment cet élément là que
retenu l'attention c'est plus le signal
qui est qui devancé pour les hausses de
taux j'aurais aussi sur
l'assouplissement quantitatif ce qui est
important de surveiller ce qui se fait
non pas au canada mais aux états unis et
aux états unis la réserve fédérale est
encore en train d'augmenter son bilan on
va commencer ce processus le qui était
commence au canada en avril avec
seulement commencé au mois de novembre
on devrait avoir complété programme de
juillet sûr que les états unis ont une
énorme influence sur les taux à travers
le monde y compris au canada et je pense
que c'était un pack look qui va être
plus important plus que
l'assouplissement quantitatif qu'on a
fait ici au canada juste pour rester sur
ce thème le ce que c'est pour avoir un
impact qui est annoncée aujourd'hui sur
les taux à moyen long terme sur les taux
fixes aux tensions sont parle pour les
particuliers qui ont des prêts
hypothécaires c'est déjà en cours on
voit déjà une très forte augmentation
des taux des taux obligataires canadiens
depuis le mois de septembre on s'attend
à ce que ça se poursuive évidemment et
sociaux en lien avec un sentier de taux
directeur qui vont être plus élevé donc
il y aura justement sur les marchés pour
tenir compte de cette réalité là et ça
se fait sentir donc les gens qui
cherchent une hypothèque qui veulent
emprunter vont devoir s'attendre à payer
plus en frais hypothécaires mais ce que
ça va aussi faire en sorte c'est que les
taux à la qualification vont augmenter
on sait que
il faut se qualifier en 1 to qui est
encore plus élevé que le taux qui est
qui est affichée au qui est sûr le
contrat donc ça va faire en sorte que ça
va être plus difficile d'accéder à
l'immobilier mais ça fait partie aussi
des intentions c'est de calmer la
demande et l'immobilier au coeur de la
transmission de la politique monétaire
vers l'économie réelle les prêts
hypothécaires justement sont à des
niveaux record ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter
d'une hausse plus rapide des taux
maintenant avec les taux variables et
variable qui découle directement du taux
directeur
c'est certain que ça va dans cette
direction là encore une fois quand la
banque du canada a amené les taux au
plancher pendant la pandémie c'était
pour ça c'était pour stimuler l'activité
immobilière c'était pour soutenir le
marché de l'habitation parce qu'on en
avait besoin dans une crise sans
précédent et le marché immobilier ont
répondu à l'appel de toute évidence on a
vu une effervescence la cellule temps de
passer à un autre un autre chapitre est
effectivement c'est de ces hausses de
taux là vont faire en sorte que ça va
être plus difficile ça va faire en sorte
que le marché devrait se calmer jimmy
jean économiste en chef chez desjardins
merci pour votre passage ce soir plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit